Okay. So some balance. Some balances are our mast cell stabilizer or you can think of
as just inflammation just dampening it down. You know, of course you don't let them
keep eating the tunnels and Cheetos and things and put them on this, but you're trying
to balance out and you're giving them a leg up. The ingredients in this will help stabilize
that mast cell. So PEA, so it's found in things like chocolates known for its calming
effect because that's endogenous lipid modulator. There's a ton of research on this particular
compound on more than 50 years. So they discovered it I think in the 70s and Nobel laureate
really studied it. That's all he's studied for years and years trying to figure out the
mechanism of a PEA. It's been studied in a lot of pain syndromes. There's a lot of randomized
controlled where they put people who had compression nerve compressions like satica, carpal
tunnel, just beat the pants off. Any anti-inflammatory said that they were using and again a lot of
clinical trials. So how does it work? How does it help with pain? You would promote feelings
of well-being and calmness. I mean, it's like the choke pill. It activates a cannabinoid
receptors. Very cool. It activates the energy boosting, fat burning, anti-inflammatory
p-part alpha. And that just activates genes that are flowing inflammatory. It reduces the
activity of the bliss gene because the bliss gene actually breaks down our natural cannabinoid.
So we're getting a calming effect and that's something I think our society really needs a calming
effect. I got flipped off going to the airport picking up Dr. Erdogan and I'm like, do you need
time balance? I'm not the best driver to that. So from the paper that talks about the real
sciencey stuff, I thought Eric would like this. The PEA acting on that p-part, acting on those
receptors. So I put that in there if you really want to read the science behind that.
I'm sure Eric will put it as quick, quick, quick. So some studies on PEA. It's anti-inflammatory,
especially the neurological system. So this is a meta-analysis. And the findings of this
support the notion that new therapeutic opportunities for chronic pain might be based on anti-inflammatory
and pro-resolving mediators that act on immune cells. That is just so cool. They're like, okay,
we have an opioid epidemic and the end says they're not the best. So we're going to figure this out
and we're going to go after the mass cells in the glia. I don't know what you guys, but I find a lot
of this chronic pain that people are in. Look, it's coming from the brain. So yeah, they're just so
inflamed in this mass cell and it's putting out all these mediators and things and it's like, good,
this sounds like a good plan. Through the literature over and over again, PEA has no adverse side effects.
There's not one thing that's listed that's even a medication interaction, which is important because
our patients are on a lot of medication. Listen to podcasts with the medical doctor talking about,
you know, alternatives for opioids. And it was anti-depressants and benzoes. So benzoes tend to have more
addictive and waiting more fully detoxing. That's what is going to be the solution close just like
alternative. Yeah. Right. There is a study to, there's a couple of them that has PEA and clinical
trials with depression too. And they're, they're pairing it with some of the typicals and getting
a better response. I'm like, it's probably just PEA. Yeah. That's getting a better response. PEA,
this is what that Nobel laureate, he studied a lot with cold and flu. So I'm, okay, that's great.
So there's a really good paper effective and safe and take it against influenza and the con and cold.
So the literature says the pharmacology of PEA and first data on the therapeutic efficacy of some
of its new formulations. What this is saying right here is that the combination of PEA with flavonoids
is a good idea. So guess what we did? We put it in a pill so that we can all enjoy it. So we took
the luteolin, which is the flavonoid and we put it in sun balance. So it's our number two ingredient in
sun balance is the luteolin. Lots of data to support the synergy between these two. So that,
so it's a flavonoid. It's found in lots of fruits and vegetables and time. We're very familiar with that.
During in vitro and in vivo analysis, it has anti-inflammatory neuro protective properties.
Dr. Theoretis, the master of the, the master of the mast cell, he talks a lot about luteolin,
when she loves luteolin. And if you go to his, his website is masselmaster.com. He states all
kinds of studies about how luteolin is protective and stabilizes really well the mast cell. You can
get, again, anything in your practice that's aggravated with stress or pain is aggravated by stress.
You can give this a try. And then in this study, the luteolin formulation, the flavonoid luteolin
has antioxidant, anti-inflammatory, anti-allergy and neuro protective properties. Sounds good to me.
Oh, and this one, when they had the combination, so they actually studied it together. This was
actually a product that was done in Germany. It was called gliolil. And it's not available anymore.
And the, the mast cell, or they, Dr. Klinghardt and his group were achieving like mast cell online.
And a lot of autism, they were using a ton of it. And it was like this uproar when they couldn't find it.
There's really no good replacement. But now there's some balance. And some balance is a really good
replacement. So they're using it to counter. This wasn't an Iraq. It wasn't a human. But they're
using it to counteract the inflammation and oxidative stress of Parkinson's disease. And it did it really
well. And it also had some autophagy properties. So autophagies are cellular cleaning mechanisms that
are really in full force when you're not eating. Some nutrients can also
upregulate autophagy. And then we added corsetins. I think corsetins are wonderful compound.
I love that it can serve the NAD. But that's what you just said. It does. It can serve
that NAD consumption. And that helps your mitochondria. It helps your energy. But it's also a flavonoid.
And it's it's been known to both these published studies review viral illness. And it can have some
positive effects if you're going to be under stress. It's protecting you probably through this
mechanism right here. And it's also a nice mast cell stabilizer. There's some study on corsetin.
It's more effective than this drug. I'm blocking the mast cells right there inhibiting IL-8,
T-N-T-N-F-Alpha release from the mast cells. And it reduces IL-6. So all that that is positive.
And this one right here dramatically inhibits the mast cell. It's just the same thing. Good stuff.
And there's the paper on. And you guys will have these slides. Why it's important to keep that ratio
reduced. So you want more NAD and less NADH. And you can do that by way of the CD-38.